welcome to Lake View cabin I say this is
a while ago he proposed remember man
this game was [ __ ] weird
so he made a full version of it it's
pretty awesome it said it's on my my own
store even how about that you can check
out the game and support charity I'm
plugging that [ __ ] don't even give a
[ __ ]
link is in description if you like what
you see I expected I expect to be
shocked and
jumpscared different kind of shocked and
what the hell is this a box
oh my god I'm snake look at this did I
die is it over we're here
hey how's everyone everyone doing that's
you lake view cabin I'm naked going for
a swim now hey bird I have a bucket I
want to ride the my back yeah yeah baby
what's up ah I'm sorry I'm sorry
why did you know ah Jin deers don't have
souls
Oh easy dude oh God Oh
sorry Lisa
sorry Ramona's and sorry Mickey
here's a present don't be upset
Oh beer look there it is let's drink a
lot of beer
Oh Lise Vicky Vicky I'm sorry it's not
me it's the alcohol back back yeah I'm
coming
no wait what am i doing okay I can
change character I'm Lisa hey Nick o get
rekt scrub ken Becky get and it's now
it's official Swedish lake house party
good times
Sabitha benya better be easy but don't
fight me rake up this rake is winning
this battle damage rake let's not write
the bike of death for now your moment
will come back a bit I love you what a
fun day the mean guy Jerry oh god no I
hit Lisa chairman I'm so sorry it's Lisa
dead Lisa she's fine alright she's still
able Gerry stupid oh you got Rick Gerry
we got Rick ah [ __ ] the rake are the
reach ah oh my god this is very nice
I just better destroy all of it hey we
even have beds and [ __ ] so much to
explore in this game oh my god alright
as if you just walk here OOP that's
awkward
[Music]
all right Oh Denise the toilet oh god no
not girls doing it you're wearing your
pants that's how much did you eat this
is fun
I can fix stuff all right so now maybe
we can fix the bridge how about that um
don't go now uh I broke my leg of a
pirate now yard yeah don't ride a bike
Lisa Lisa Lisa J price later now next
monster do your dog and your friends are
dead that scooter is really a scooter of
death it's not go near it
okay who should go
koonta what's that your name probably
wasn't a [ __ ] good job ah good to be
careful good job
Edgar what are you doing I don't know
man I'm just a potato
I am so tempted let's do it just because
I'm going to 9 he became a pizza yeah
mommy yeah
okay that was nothing Edgar oh god damn
hurts
I saw the pizza I'm like all that was
spoken delicious taste the German I
don't know why so I think I have matches
here oh thank god no Edgar's on the
other side I got your purse I can't swim
no again no ah [ __ ] ah ah don't worry I
got you here I got you don't run don't
run run it up Lisa
oh just Edgar does that does shut all
right [ __ ] it all
Lisa save him you must say that you know
what's supposed to be this way no oh god
there it is no kill you Russ help me out
if you have the game buy it on my store
it does support charities so it's a cool
thing and figure out for me how to play
because I don't really don't know but
that's all for me for now
ice always froze thank you so much for
watching and leaving a like I really
appreciate it and becoming a pro by
subscribing and I'll see you in the next
video as always stay awesome breasts
[Music]
but now
[Music]